now you can see why in Part B it says
where else where else is it at rest
right because I already know one place
it's at rest namely name of the x equals
to x equals 2 it is at rest so there's
somewhere else that it's also addressed
right ok now you can maybe menu just see
all it has to be negative 2 because
because why why is it obvious ok so you
can just look at the numbers but you can
also remember what kind of motion is
this again I think it's simple harmonic
motion right so if it's at rest here
that must be one of the extremities so
your other extremities on the opposite
side same distance right but I am going
to go through with the alt-rock I'm
going to say this is Pawn a heartbeat
I'm just going to let the equal zero and
solve again right so when V equals 0 16
I'm just doing
okay now i think it's important by the
way at this point what I've done is I've
solved the equation I'm not going to
write down X equals needed to
straightaway why not mighty that's a bad
idea because I've just left off a
solution for what for what reason the
reason is you're actually interpreting
what's going on ok so there's much
saving to actually give all of the
solutions you get right and then exclude
the ones that don't make sense because
you've already counted four right so i
can say but the weight started out in
one of these values right started or one
of those
so this accounts for why I'm excluding
one solution and only taking the
negative one okay I already accounted
for the executor that's where I started
so I just want the second one me yes so
by the way there's a better way to say
this right when I introduce meters
remember we introduced all this plus 2
minus 2 the whole coordinate system that
wasn't part of the question so therefore
what does that actually exit was never
to does that actually mean sumit is
below this arm yeah well even the origin
is something I introduced right so I
guess we could say resting for you could
call it equilibrium that's another word
that means stay put it's not going
anywhere okay so I'm gonna say I it's
also at rest of this equals a YouTube IE
2 meters below now at this point I'm
kind of stepping on myself a little bit
because I've said it's at rest 2 meters
below its resting point but um so long
as you define carefully please don't
like I said you use whatever label you
want the point at which it isn't moving
if you if it's sitting on the runway so
long as your ID ambiguous about what's
where your fun last one what am I going
to do maximum speed
okay so if i were to say against simple
harmonic motion i know that the maximum
speed occurs at the center of mission so
i can take advantage of that that's fine
but what if what if it wasn't just
simple harmonic motion what could I do
to find remember this is my equation
right b squared equals 16 minus 4x
squared what am I going to do to find
the matteson for that should just live
don't be limited this is variation there
you differentiate yes which is what hmm
isn't it when x equals x legitimization
yeah it's a solution take stairs and
over to the common choice so yeah I know
the answer it is but I don't know how to
get there okay so there's a few
different things like that two main
things I'm going to save me firstly
firstly do not talk about finding
stationary points don't talk about
finding stationary points right because
what you're talking about is
differentiating with respect to time
that's the kind of station where you're
talking about you can't do that I have
nothing to do with time at the moment
see me only s okay now I can say I know
what the actual acceleration is right so
if you think about this way you should
be able to find the maximum velocity
when there's no acceleration acting on
you so that makes sense because you no
longer changing you're not getting
faster anymore you've hit the maximum
right that's the first part that you can
take through there's another easier way
it's another easy way you try to
maximize baby right you're trying to
find a biggest value for V not worry
about site okay so do you agree that the
bees value for being occurs when v
square is also the biggest it can be
right biggest v will be the biggest
piece / can someone tell me what kind of
lotion
it's just a parabola just a parabola Oh
be careful and and then you got to be
careful about like I'm not talking about
20 points so much is the fact that this
value here I just want to minimize that
right this is the only thing that makes
this smaller egg it always has been
positive energy right the smallest of
this park and possibly is zero okay so
therefore maximum speed occurs when I
want this thing this minus 4x squared to
be equal to 0 right that does tell me
therefore I will clearly left the origin
right but actually the question itself
it's just what is the maximum speed so
IE v square is just 16 take away 0 Thank
You of that plus you're not my son's get
beat up here it doesn't matter it see
what so therefore V is going to be plus
or minus 4 but of course I'm interested
in is steam so the unity are meters and
seconds so I go maximum speed four
minutes per second yes
okay so have a look at this function
here right you've got a concert and
you've got some number making that
constant smaller right affecting that
constant I want this thing to be small
right the bigger this is the smaller the
overall number is the smallest this
thing carboxyl with E is zero because
it's squid right so there that's it by
the way I could make exactly the same
argument in a different way suppose I
didn't know that suppose I had like 16
take away sine X and this was the
velocity squared function okay how would
we go about applying a similar kind of
logic took that careful careful oh I
said zero because it's square the
smallest this can possibly be is zero
because we're ah the smallest that sine
X can possibly be is negative 1 right so
if this will be square right the maximum
v squared occurs when sine x equals
negative 1 that's a smallest impossible
yet right so therefore these square will
be 16 take away negative 1 it will be 17
so therefore your maximum speed out of
that does that make sense so think
carefully about the function what you're
trying to do with it right if it's a
square make it zero if it's something
else think about the particular
characteristics that that function has